if you're looking for ways to think
critically stop making excuses and make
something of yourself
then this video is for you you need to
learn to think because thinking makes
you act effectively in the world
thinking makes you win the battles you
undertake like there's no excuse
whatsoever for not getting at what it is
that you should be doing stand up for
yourself like a respectable human being
and be a bit of a light on the world
instead of a blight need motivation
watch a top ten would believe nation
what's up it's Evan my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
in that amazing gift you have inside you
that I want to see come out so let's get
your motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
on today's lessons from a man who grew
up in a small town in Canada to a
librarian mother and school teacher
father to becoming a Harvard and
University of Toronto professor and
having over half a million subscribers
on YouTube not bad for a professor he's
Jordan P Peterson and here's my take on
his top 10 real success vol 2
alright let's take it off with rule
number one set up criteria for success
but one of the main reasons that people
do get what they want is because they
don't actually figure out what it is and
the probability that you're going to get
what would be good for you let's say
which would even be better than what you
want right because you know you might be
what wrong about what you want easily
but maybe you could get what would
really be good for you well why don't
you well because you don't try you don't
think okay here's what I would like if I
could have it and and I don't mean I
don't mean in a way that you manipulate
the world to force it to deliver you
goods for status or something like that
that isn't what I mean I mean something
like imagine that you were taking care
of yourself like you were someone you
actually cared for and then you thought
okay I'm caring for this person I would
like things to go as well for them as
possible
what would their life have to be like in
order for that to be the case well
people don't do that they don't sit down
and think alright you know let's let's
figure it out you've got a life it's
hard obviously it's like three years
from now you can have what you need you
got to be careful about it you can't
have everything you can have what would
be good for you but you have to figure
out what it is and then you have to aim
at it well my experience with people as
being is if they figure out what it is
that would be good for them and then
they aim at it then they get it and it's
strange because they don't necessarily
tan idea about what would be good for
you and then you take ten steps towards
that and you find out that your
formulation was a bit off and so you
have to reformulate your goal you know
you're kind of going like this as you
move towards the goal but a huge part of
the reason that people fail is because
they don't ever set up the criteria for
success and so since success is a very
narrow line and very unlikely the
probability that you're going to stumble
on it randomly is zero and so there's a
proposition here in the proposition is
if you actually want something
you can have it now the question then
would be well what do you mean by
actually want and the answer is that you
reorient your life in every possible way
to make the probability that that will
occur as certain as possible and that's
a sacrificial idea right it's like you
don't get everything obviously you
obviously but maybe you can have what
you need and maybe all you have to do to
get it is ask but asking isn't a whim or
today's wish it's like you have to be
deadly serious about it you have to
think okay like I'm taking stock of
myself and if I was going to live
properly in the world and I was going to
set myself up such that being would
justify itself in my estimation and I
don't mean as a harsh judge exactly what
is it that I would aim at sit on your
bed one day and ask yourself what's what
remarkably stupid things am i doing on a
regular basis to absolutely screw up my
life and if you actually ask that
question but you have to want to know
the answer right because that's actually
what asking the question means it
doesn't mean just mouthing the words it
means you have to decide that you want
to know you'll figure that's how it's so
fast it'll make your hair curl I love
this message and rule number two in the
top ten was a success the one that comes
up over and over and over again is have
self-awareness to understand what it is
that you want to go on and achieve what
it is in your daily schedule that is
holding you back having a self-awareness
having the courage to ask the question
and then having the ability to create
goals for yourself that are in line with
who you are and when you ask you want to
accomplish that's the game so I love
this number one great way to kick us off
let's move into rule number two learn to
think critically the best thing you can
do is teach people to write because
there's no difference between that and
thinking and one of the things that just
blows me away about universities is that
no one ever tells students why they
should write something it's like well
you have to do this assignment well why
are you writing well you need the grade
it's like no you need to learn to think
thinking makes you act effectively in
the world thinking makes you win the
battles you undertake and those could be
battles for good things if you can think
and speak and write you are absolutely
deadly nothing can get in your way
so that's why you learn to write it's
like why I can't believe that people
aren't just told that it's it's it's
like it's the most powerful weapon you
can possibly provide someone with and I
mean I know lots of people who have been
staggeringly successful and watched them
throughout my life I mean those people
you don't want to have an argument with
them they'll just slash you into pieces
and then not in a malevolent way it's
like if you're gonna make your point and
they're gonna make their point you
better have your points organized
because otherwise you were gonna look
like and be an absolute idiot you are
not going to get anywhere and if you can
formulate your arguments coherently and
make a presentation if you can speak to
people if you can lay out a proposal God
people give you money they give you
opportunities you have influence I agree
I think the ability to think critically
as well as to communicate whether that's
writing whether that's making videos
whether that's giving speeches the
ability to influence people is important
you're on a mission you have a dream
you're trying to accomplish something
you can't do it alone you need people to
come on board with you and that's gonna
come from your ability to persuade them
that your mission is important and they
should join you in your cause so the key
for me is just practice practice
practice practice practice writing
practice speaking practice making videos
practice having conversations you will
suck the first time through and the more
you practice the better you're gonna get
let's move to rule number three don't be
harmless if you're harmless you're not
virtuous you're just harmless you're
like a rabbit rabbit isn't virtuous it's
just just can't do anything except get
eaten it's not virtuous if you're a
monster and you don't act monstrously
then you're virtuous but you also have
to be a monster while you see this all
the time Harry Potter's like that too
it's like he's he's flawed he's hurt
he's got evil in him he can talk to
snakes man he breaks rules all the time
all the time he's not an obedient at all
but you know he has a good reason for
breaking the rules and if he couldn't
break the rules him and his little
clique of rule breaking you know
troublemakers if they didn't break the
rules
they wouldn't attain the highest goal so
it's very peculiar but it's it's very
there it's a very very very very common
mythological notion you know the hero
has to be the hero has to be a monster
but a controlled monster Batman is like
that you know I mean it's it's
everywhere it's it's the Tor story you
always hear so I really love the idea of
the entrepreneur hero being the rule
breaker of being the person who sees
something in a different way we don't
accept the status quo we're not doing
something to harm people we're not
breaking rules that get us into massive
trouble or is causing somebody death or
some major problem but we're going
against the status quo because we
believe in a better future and to make
that happen we have to break the rules
of what's happened right now moving on
the rule number four is compare yourself
to who you were yesterday Rule four
compare yourself to who you were
yesterday and not to who someone else is
today because if you're comparing
yourself to someone else I mean first of
all you don't know very much about the
life of the person you're comparing
yourself to you don't know innit you
know what across all of its dimensions
and second people are very different and
so comparing yourself to someone else
it's it's kind of useful I guess when
you're young but as you get older and
more singular and more particularly it
becomes increasingly less useful better
to compare yourself to a previous
version of yourself and work for
improvement in that way the only thing I
would add here is that I think comparing
yourself to somebody else can be useful
if it's to get yourself to move forward
if you compare yourself to Steve Jobs
and that inspires you to want to do
something bigger and that can be helpful
if you use it just as I'll never be as
good as Steve Jobs or have that big an
impact then it's not that helpful I
think the comparison is good as long as
it's a kick forward and not a kick down
and again comparing to yourself of who
you were yesterday measuring that impact
and improvement is also super helpful
let's go
rule number five start small I know you
stated in the last lecture that the
importance for setting aims in life and
to kind of have goals to work towards
right so my question was where do you
how do you do that if you don't know
where you want to go because that's kind
of where I got stuck on you're your
future off offering program because okay
that's that's a good question that's a
really good question so there's this
notion in the Old Testament that
morality is following a sequence of
prohibitions there's a bunch of bad
things you shouldn't do and then
basically you're good enough and and and
I think there's wisdom in that I think
that's kind of where children start
right you I mean I love children and all
that but they're they're they're crazy
little creatures and they need to be you
know civilized and partly what you do is
you you lay prohibitions on them and
mostly what you're trying to do is lay
prohibitions on them for the behaviors
that if they manifested would make their
life miserable so this is why this thing
that I've said the people has become
this crazy internet meme but that's to
clean up your room and which which is a
lot better and more useful than people
think it's a lot harder to but the thing
the first thing you do I think and I
learned this in part from Solzhenitsyn
when he was trying to iron out his soul
when he was in the gulag because he was
trying to figure out how he got there
how he contributed to how he got there
you know not Stellan and Hitler even
though they were kind of to blame you
know but he wasn't much he could do
about that I think what you have to do
and this is part of humility is you have
to look around you within your sphere of
influence like the direct sphere of
influence and fix the things that
announce themselves as in need of repair
and those are often small things you
know and they can be like your room put
it in order because the thing is it
isn't exactly so important that your
room is in order although it is what's
important is that you learn how to
distinguish between chaos and order and
to be able to act in a manner that
produces order and I think you can you
can do something as simple as just sit
on your bed and think okay there's
probably like five things I could do
today so that tomorrow morning is slide
better than this morning was at least or
at least I'm not falling behind and
those will usually be it's like having
to eat a toad in the morning right it's
like it's not gonna be something you
want to do there'll be things you're
trying to avoid there's snakes
essentially but if you ask yourself like
you're asking someone which i think is a
form of prayer if you ask yourself
instead of telling yourself you know
what is it that I could do to set things
more right today that I would actually
do it's usually some small thing because
you're not that disciplined you know
then you can go do it and then you you
put the world together a little more
when you do that and that spreads out
but you also put your you also construct
yourself into something that's better
able to call order forth from chaos and
that makes you just incrementally
stronger and then the next day you can
maybe take on a slightly larger task and
like you get the benefit of compound
interest if you do that it's a
tremendously powerful technique and they
think if you do that at some point
instead of just having to fix things up
that are not good you'll start to get a
glimmer of the positive things that you
could do you know the positive things
that you could do that would actually
constitute a vision and now that's what
I would recommend it's another message
that you hear over and over and over
again is you start small you have this
big goal of where you want to go and
there's a lot that can be done a lot
that you can do and often that can be
super overwhelming and so the key is to
start small and to do one small step
today and then another small step
tomorrow and over time those small steps
when you look back you'll have
accomplished this huge thing but you
don't just take a giant leap overnight
especially the beginning because you
suck at what you're doing and so start
small and every single day make a little
bit more progress to achieving your goal
that's how you do it let's go to rule
number six I'm gonna like this one
don't make excuses when people are beset
with a catastrophe like let's say the
death of their father that they are
prone to use that as an excuse for not
going about the business that they
should be going about because they can
say to themselves well I would accept
and accept there's always good reasons I
mean believe me there's always good
reasons for not doing what you should
that's for sure the
reasons pile up day after day to not do
what you should especially because
you're you're aiming at things in the
future you can put them off and
definitely right because of the demands
of the day like there's no excuse
whatsoever for not getting at what it is
that you should be doing
it's absolutely reprehensible to justify
your in action with the catastrophe that
extracts mercy from other people right
there's a tricky tricky game that's
going well of course I can't do that
look at the terrible thing that's just
happened to me and see how ok I
understand you're absolved of any
necessity to move forward because of
your current catastrophe it's like well
actually you're not and it's rather rude
of you to use it as an excuse and it's
certainly counterproductive so every
time I include a clip around not making
excuses it always comes off as some like
really harsh really hard non carry
non-emotional front and the thing though
is it's true like the more that you live
a life of excuses that you have somebody
else to blame something else to blame
some circumstances to blame even if it
is rightly holding you back in some
circumstance as long as you have that
other thing to blame then you never move
you stay where you are if you're not
happy with where you are and ask
yourself the reasons why and if you're
looking at anybody else besides you then
you will never get out of where you are
until you stop making those excuses and
take personal accountability for your
life let's go to rule number 7 change
yourself when I was 25 or so I probably
weighed about 138 pounds I smoked like a
pack of cigarettes day I drank
tremendous amount of alcohol I was from
northern Alberta this rough little town
up and northern Alberta called Fairview
and you know there were long winters
there and my friends were heavy drinkers
and most of them dropped out of school
by the time they were 15 or 16 went off
to work on the oil rigs and you know it
was a rough town and we drank a lot I
started when I was 14 and you know and
so I was I had a lot of bad habits let's
say and things that were and I wasn't in
great shape physically and I was also
still intellectually obsessed by as I am
now and so that would have been that
would have been in 85 but when I
but I decided around that about 85-84 or
something like that maybe a little
earlier that I was really gonna try to
get my act together and so I started
doing that I you know I first of all I
quit smoking well that took a long time
because I eventually had to quit
drinking too in order to quit smoking
and I started working out starting
playing sports which I'd never done I
had a fine time when I was a kid and but
I needed really to get disciplined and I
had to do it because I was working on
these hard problems that you know that
I've been discussing with all of you and
I've been working on them really you
know obsessively since I was probably
about 18 maybe even earlier than that
got to the point around 25 when I was in
graduate school trying to get my PhDs
doing all my research like I published
15 papers by the time I graduated with
my PhD which was but I think by a fairly
large measure the most papers that any
graduate student at that time had ever
published at McGill I think that's right
might have been twice as many or maybe
twice as many maybe even three times as
many and at the same time I wrote maps
of meaning which was a terrible terrible
terribly difficult thing to do because I
was writing about three hours a day
doing that and I couldn't do all that
and continue with my misbehavior you
know my sort of my what would you say my
my my hedonistic my hedonistic my
massive hedonistic consumption of
alcohol and all of that I just couldn't
keep it up and also work seriously on
the issues that were at hand so you know
I had to stop that's a sacrifice I had
to stop messing about and straight my
cell phone what this really highlights
to me is the importance of short-term
benefits versus long-term benefits in
the short term drinking partying smoking
really makes you feel good but it
doesn't serve your longer-term goal
doesn't serve what you want to become
and so if you have a really clear
picture of the type of person you want
to become and the type of work that you
want to do and the type of impact that
you want to have and if that's strong
enough inside you and that you really
feel viscerally it's a part of you and
that needs to happen then it's easier to
let go of these bad habits
that are preventing you from
accomplishing your big goal even though
they feel really good in the short term
so I'm curious what bad habits you might
have to give up while you think of that
let's move to rule number 8 toughen up
you're actually tougher than you think
you never knew that and maybe you didn't
want to take on the responsibility
because you know people play a role in
their own demise so to speak when you
had opportunity to go out and explore or
withdraw because you were afraid you
chose to withdraw because you were
afraid so it's not only that you were
over protected often it's that you were
willing to take advantage of the fact
that you were over protected and run
back there whenever you had the
opportunity you know so maybe you're a
kid in the playground right and you're
having some trouble with other kids and
you know in the back of your mind I
should deal this with deal with this
myself but you go and tell your mom and
get her to intervene and you know that
that's not right you know that you're
breaking the social contract but it's
easier and so that's what you do you run
off to an authority figure and hide
behind the Great Father right roughly
speaking well the problem with that is
you don't learn how to do it yourself
so then you have to relearn it painfully
when you're 40 so then you take people
out you say well what are you afraid of
ranked it from 1 to 10 so 10 is make a
list of 10 things you're afraid of the
least the thing you're least afraid of
will call number 10 so we'll start with
that
okay well I'm afraid of elevators okay
well let's let's look at a picture of an
elevator let's have you imagine being in
an elevator let's go out to an elevator
and let you watch the terrible jaws of
death open because that's how you're
responding to it symbolically right and
you're gonna do that at it at the the
closest proximity you can manage you
find out you go do that it works you're
nervous as hell especially at it from an
anticipatory perspective shaking you go
out you stop you watch it happen and you
actually calm down you do that 10 times
it no longer bothers you well what
you've learned that you didn't die but
more importantly than that you've
learned that you could withstand the
threat of death that's what you've
learned and then you move a little
closer and then you move a little closer
and then you move a little closer and
finally you're back in what's no longer
the elevator from a symbolic perspective
it's a
right it's it's it's a place of
enclosure and isolation and you learn
hmm turns out I can withstand that and
then you're met much more together much
more confident and that's often one of
the things that often happens in
situations like that I've seen this
multiple times is that if you run
someone through an exposure training
process like that and and toughen them
up they'll often start standing up to
people around them in a way they never
did before I love this rule and what I
try to remind myself and the people
around me up is whenever you're faced
with this problem that you feel is super
overwhelm and it just ginormous I remind
myself that this is just a warm-up
whatever giant problem is in front of me
right now this is just a warm-up
exercise because if you can't handle
this big thing that's in front of you
then you're not going to handle the
bigger problems and the bigger problems
and the bigger problems and if you want
to have that big impact you have to be
able to play out here not get lost these
little tiny issues that consume your
life and so use that as a training tool
the next time you feel overwhelmed by
something the next time something is
just so important and taking up all your
hours then remind yourself this is just
the warmup and you're capable of
handling a heck of a lot more let's go
to rule number nine find your winning
strategy if you concentrate solely on
your career you can get a long way in
your career and I would say that that's
a strategy that a minority of men
preferentially do that that's all they
do
they worked like 70 80 hours a week they
go flat out on their career they're
staking everything on the small
probability of exceptional status in a
narrow domain but it's it's hard on them
they don't have a life it's very
difficult for them to have a family they
don't know how to take any leisure
activity like they get very
one-dimensional now it may be that that
unit dimensionality is the price you
have to pay to be exceptional at one
thing right because if you're going to
be something like a genius level
mathematician and you want to do that
for a scientist say it's like you're in
your lab you're in your lab all the time
you're working 70 hours a week or 80
hours a week you're smart you're
dedicated your unit dimensional and
that's how you get to beat all the other
people who are doing that it's the only
way but the problem is you don't get a
life now if you love being a
scientists and you have that kind of
focus of mind well first of all you're a
rare person and second you're gonna pay
for it but find more power to you but
but it's a it's a risky business to do
that you sacrifice a lot for it you know
and I would say most often if you're
speaking about having a healthy life
that isn't what you do you spread
yourself out more so you know you have a
family you have some things that you do
outside of work that are meaningful to
you and useful you you have a network of
friends that those three things a loner
four things alone are plenty to keep you
well oriented and then if one of those
things collapses
you know everything doesn't go now the
price you pay for that is the more you
strive to optimize that balance the less
likely you are to be fantastically
successful at any single one of them but
you might have a very you know if you
couldn't consider your life as a whole
that might be a winning strategy the
most important part here for me is that
you just find the right balance for you
and how everybody defines balance is
gonna be different the number of hours
worked and number of time spent with
family the number of days on vacation
per year there's no right or wrong you
can model somebody and try out what
they're doing but the only version of
right for you is going to be what you
want to do and through that
experimentation you find the right
winning strategy for yourself instead of
just trying to live up to somebody else
as an expectation of what you should and
should not be doing let's wrap it up
before moving the rule number 10 make
yourself into something right a plumber
once you know it was the night it was
the night before we were putting drywall
in our house we were redoing a house and
he had put in all the plastic piping you
know and I was gonna test the joints
steel are supposed to be glued together
with this pipe glue right and I said I
told him I had to test the joints and he
said well you don't have to test my
joints they never leak and I thought
yeah that's okay
how about if I test them so I went up on
the third floor and filled the pipes
with water capping them in the basement
like you're supposed to and like half an
hour later I had two inches of water in
the basement there were thirty leaking
joints that was the night before the
drywallers were supposed to show up so
well so he wasn't particularly competent
that's the point of that story
but even more so he had put a bunch of
the plastic pipe outside where the
drywall would be so it would have been
sticking through the wall so I spent a
frenetic night you know sawing through
plastic pipe and reglue in joints so
that my huh well so that the dry
worlders could come in what's the point
if you're going to be a plumber man be a
good plumber because otherwise all you
do is go out there and cause trouble we
don't need people to cause more trouble
we need people to solve problems you
know and so you can be a tradesman and
you can be to make a lot of money as a
trades person it's a bloody reliable
honorable forthright productive way of
making a living and there is a hell of a
lot of difference between a working man
who knows what he's doing and one who
doesn't both in terms of skill and
ethics right and you work with someone
who knows what they're doing it's a
bloody pleasure they tell you what
they're gonna do they tell you how much
it will cost they go and do it it works
and you pay them perfect everyone's
happy and that's what happens when you
have genuine hierarchies of competence
and so you till you listen to these
panderers of egalitarian gely
egalitarianism and equity and they fail
to recognize completely that there are
differences in rank between people it's
not such a terrible thing man
maybe you wouldn't be a great lawyer
like it's certainly possible most people
aren't but that doesn't mean there isn't
something you could be great at there's
lots of hierarchies to attempt to climb
and if you fail in one go try in another
but the point is you're still trying to
aim for the top and what the hell are
you gonna do if you don't try to aim for
the top you know flap about uselessly
and whine about your life it's not
helpful it'll just make you miserable
you're not reliable to anyone you can't
help out in a crisis it's like so you
tell young people and this is another
message for conservatives like I don't
care what you're gonna do but go out
there make something of yourself for
God's sake be an honest person and work
and get to the top of whatever it is
that you want to get to the top of you
know and and and and then stand up for
yourself like a respectable human being
and be a bit of a light on the world
instead of a blight you know and you can
tell young people that and they haven't
been told that by anyone now and so the
young men are so hungry for that that
it's it's painful to watch
they're so relieved when font was
someone finally
something says hey you know you you get
your act together a bit discipline
yourself see if you can learn to tell
the truth concentrate on something for a
year or two you could be a bloody world
beater they think really that's possible
wow that would be that would be
interesting that might make life or life
worth living it's like yeah it might so
why don't you go do it that's what the
damn universities were supposed to be
teaching people they've forgotten that I
went to Harvard a month ago months and a
half you used to teach there and I
talked to a bunch of students you know
what I told them it's not easy to get
into Harvard you know like you're a
valedictorian if you're at Harvard and
not only are you a valedictorian you're
way better than most people at at least
two other things or you don't get in and
so that gets I don't know what the
acceptance rate is like 5% and believe
me not everybody applies so it's a very
selective school and so why am I saying
that it's like these are high quality
kids so I told them what I just told you
it's like here you are at Harvard it's
like get yourself educated man read some
books learn to talk learn to think make
yourself into something get the hell out
there and make the world that put you
here happy that you were put there in
that great institution you know and they
came up to me afterwards and said god I
wish someone would have told us that
when we were in our first year it's like
Jesus why didn't someone tell them that
for God's sake it's supposed to be the
greatest university in the world is it
so difficult to figure that out I really
like the line of be a light unto the
world instead of a blight I love that
one and I think listen just what
entrepreneurs do is what we try to do
every day right we try to make the world
a better place we try to turn ourselves
into something we try to we have this
idea of how things could be better and
then we want to go out and create it and
so just hold on to it because it's hard
because you're gonna get failures you're
gonna get pushback you give it people
telling you that it's never gonna work
out just hold on to that dream and every
single day whatever helps you believe in
yourself more get up do that and make
yourself into something
that's my take on Jordan Peterson's top
ten rules a success volume two I would
say number six don't complain is my
personal favorite I'd love to hear from
you is number six don't complain your
favorite or is there a better one that
has a more immediate impact on you and
why leaving the comments below I really
want to hear from you now I made this
video because dude what to12 asked me to
if there's a famous entrepreneur that
you all made a profile next check the
link in description and go and cast your
vote on the request line I also want to
give a quick chat a to Daniel Daniel
thank you so much man for picking up a
copy of my book your one word and
posting the review on your website and
tweeting about it as well I really
really appreciate the support man and
I'm so glad you enjoyed the book so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love see you soon
you're lost and the problem with being
lost is when you're lost you don't know
where to go and the problem with not
knowing where to go is there's a million
places that you could go and a million
places is too many places for you to go
without dying
so being lost is not good so you need to
know where you are and you can kind of
tell if you don't know where you are
it's quite straightforward if you are
haunted by reveries of the past for
events that are older than approximately
18 months if they continue to come up in
your mind over and over and your dreams
over and over
you haven't extracted the world out from
your past experiences the potential is
still trapped in the past and to
confront the potential means to confront
the dragon of the past and of course
that's terrifying and it can seriously
be terrifying so you're navigating
you're a navigator you're a sailor on an
ocean man that's what that's what you
are you're a mobile creature you're
going from point A to point B all the
time you know it's sitting there glued
to a rock like some brainless you know
sea creature there's a funny little
creature called a Hydra very simple
little creature in its juvenile stage it
has a brain because it swims around but
then when it turns into an adult it
latches itself to a rock and promptly
digests it's brain because if you're
just sitting on a rock and you're not
moving you don't need a brain so but
that's not our issue right we're we're
zipping around in the world and so we're
navigating agents so to navigate there's
two things you need to know the first is
where the hell are you exactly precisely
right razorsharp
what's good about you and what's bad
about you by your own by your own
reckoning you don't have to you can ask
other people but this is a game you play
yourself it's like as far as I'm
concerned I'm taking start what is it
that's okay about me and what needs some
work and you got to watch to not be too
self-critical when you're doing that too
because that can just be another kind of
flaw raise your standard Apple at the
core is core value
is that movie that people have passion
and change the way people not one drop
of myself work depends on your
acceptance to me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten roses success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link the description for details